second story today about separation of
church and state going from education to
the justice system the way our justice
system is supposed to work I guess the
way it normally works although not
always is that a judge presides over a
trial to ensure that everything is
carried out in accordance with the law
jury selection how arguments are made in
court how witnesses are questioned what
evidence is acceptable the judge makes
sure that the jury gets the correct
instructions that they're able to
deliberate in private without undue
influence from outside forces but in
none other than the state of Texas State
District Judge Jack Robeson decided to
interrupt the deliberations of the jury
to tell them that God spoke to him and
believes that the defendant Gloria
Romero Perez should be found not guilty
of trafficking a teen girl for sex
he said when God tells me I got to do
something I got to do it the good news
is that the jury was not influenced by
the judge they came back with a guilty
verdict despite the judges claim that
God thinks the woman should have been
found not guilty the judge was replaced
by a different judge for the sentencing
phase and ultimately the sentence is 25
years in prison now there should be and
there likely will be an investigation
into the judge this might be a stupid
question I know that as a non-religious
person I might not understand the
complexities and intricacies of how God
works but if God wanted the child sex
trafficker found not guilty wouldn't God
have communicated that directly to the
jury or maybe have done something to
prevent the trial from even starting or
is this one we can apply that old phrase
I think it's God works in mysterious
ways I think it's the free will thing
you know that people have the free will
to bring these people to court and they
have their day in court and humans
decide that and God can intervene but
then why would God tell the judge go and
try to intervene with the jury it
doesn't make any sense right I think
that's why they often fall back on that
phrase God works in mysterious ways
this is a version of Sharia law right
it's it's Christian Sharia law where the
judge is deciding
but God wants the result of a trial to
be this is exactly the kind of activist
judge that the right says they're
against except maybe when it's their
Christian God supposedly influencing the
jury and if you or I did this it would
be jury tampering of course to be held
in contempt of court and we'd probably
go to prison for a little while and
rightfully so not only that if you just
replace in the story a Texas with Saudi
Arabia people would be saying hey this
is proof of how insane and backwards
they are in that part of the world and
they'd be right but don't we need to
apply the exact same standard to this
because it's the exact same thing
hopefully that investigation will happen
and hopefully the judge is disbarred
I'll let you know if and when that
happens